monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre j'aurais préféré vous
souhaiter la bonne année je le fais
quand même
mais vous comprendrez que depuis cette
interview du président de la république
aussi d'ailleurs sidérante que désolante
limo d'émail macron sont dans tous les
esprits et ces mots je ne lai
prononcerai pas je ne les prenant serais
pas ici au sénat et je ne prononcerai
pas non plus parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
droit de cité dans notre conversation
civile aucune urgence sanitaire aucune
urgence sanitaire ne justifie des propos
d'une telle brutalité d'une telle
indignité
aucune nécessité épidémique ne légitime
qu'un président de la république
qu'un président de la république aille
jusqu à dénier à ses propres
compatriotes
la qualité de concitoyens
monsieur le premier ministre celui qui
vous parle est vaccinée j'ai voté vous
le savez le pass sanitaires et je
voterai le pass vaccinale malgré ces
provocation calculée
malgré le piège qui nous est tendu mes
chers collègues monsieur le premier
ministre je vous interroge dans une
france qui est tellement fracture est
morcelé archipel ise pensez vous qu'il
faille en rajouter encore en division en
dix corps monsieur le premier ministre
alors que notre débat public est pollué
de plus en plus par la violence pensez
vous vraiment que la réponse à la
violence c'est une autre forme de
violence violence verbale vous avez été
maire ya si peu et je voudrais interrogé
maintenant l'homme que vous est cher
jean castex maire auriez vous utilisez
ces mots là avec ce sens là c'est la
question
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président retailleau d'abord
eu je vous souhaite ainsi qu'à tout le
sénat une bonne année très
chaleureusement être très sincèrement et
évidemment je ne suis pas tout à fait
surpris de votre question
et je vais si vous voulez bien me placer
au fond du sujet
oui oui oui oui
vous savez cher président vous êtes
belle histoire comme moi vous savez bien
que ces termes que vous ne voulez pas
prononcé avait déjà été prononcée par un
oui oui
mais quel est le sujet au fond quel est
le sujet
qui renvoie à la politique que nous
conduisons pour faire face à crise
sanitaire au moment je n'ai pas besoin
de rappeler au sénat où notre pays est
confronté à nouveau à une vague d'une
forte ampleur où nos hôpitaux et nos
soignants sont confrontés vous le savez
à une situation extrêmement difficile
oui oui mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs nous ne cessons de le dire
nous avons une difficulté avec celles et
ceux de nos concitoyens qui ne sont pas
vaccinés
oui nous avons l'impérieuse nécessité
comme le faisons depuis des mois de
faire progresser la vaccination dans ce
pays et vous savez je vous entends mais
quand comme vous je n'en doute pas je
vais sur le terrain vous avez bien voulu
cher présent faire allusion à mes
anciennes fonctions de maire comme qu'on
vous je me rend très régulièrement dans
les services de soins critiques ce qu'a
dit le président de la république
je l'entend partout
mais oui
est il bien sûr que oui et vous le savez
vous le savez il y a une forme
d'exaspération de nos concitoyens à se
voir imposer un certain nombre de
contraintes alors que d'autres font le
choix de sanaa franchir avec toutes les
conséquences que ça
un point malgré cher président dans
votre question vous avez dit que vous
feriez la loi les propos du président de
la république s'inscrivent en parfaite
cohérence avec ce que nous faisons en
parfaite cohérence et vous le savez
c'est à dire poussé à la vaccination
responsabiliser toujours davantage
celles et ceux de nos concitoyens qui
s'y refusent c'est capital y compris
pour contrer l'exaspération légitime de
ceux et ils sentent eme cément nombreux
immensément nombreux qui font l'effort
de se conformer aux règles de la vie
civique alors monsieur le président nous
avons un texte qui va dans ce sens qui
va transformer vous le savez le pass
sanitaire en passe vaccinale je constate
avec regret qu'on a l'air de se servir
de tout motif pour en retarder l'examen
le tout notifs je me suis exprimé alors
cher président et il faut que nous
reprenions la marche des choses ce texte
est un outil majeur
ce n'est pas le seul c'est un outil
majeur pour lutter contre cette pandémie
qui galope je le dis au sénat nous avons
besoin de ce texte et je ne comprends
pas les obstructions au fond j'ai
consulté les groupes parlementaires
monsieur le président du sénat de
l'assemblée et du sénat il y avait un
consensus par global bien entendu avec
des nuances nous devons le capitaliser
parce que l'orientation est bonne ne
confondez pas le fond est capital j'ai
besoin la france a besoin de ce texte
pour faire progresser la vaccination
[Applaudissements]
quelques secondes quelques secondes
vous avez répondu à côté de ma question
mails macron il ya quelques jours était
venu dans une grande émission
télévisuelle pour vous dire la main sur
le coeur la larme à l'oeil qu'il avait
changé qu'il avait compris les français
qu'ils avaient appris à aimer les
français il ya encore un gros travail
ces mots là c'est pas un dérapage de
plus c'est un outrage de trop
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]